regardez bien votre calendrier c'est
aujourd'hui la chandeleur tradition
respectée en france c'est le jour des
crêpes et plus particulièrement en
bretagne dans le petit village de gourin
dans le centre de la bretagne là en
cherchant bien on peut trouver même un
centre de formation pour apprentis
crêpier jérôme blanc et christian pollet
gens vous
fromage jambon fromage quoi kraz fois là
une phrase ce quoi et croustillant
crasse et croustillant croustillantes
les crêpes de madame charpentier sont
réputés pour l'être à gourin son tour
demain est inimitable depuis plus de 20
ans elle fait le bonheur des amoureux de
la crète
gemma rose elle en breton et raclette en
français donc j'ai aussi ma shopping une
chopine de pâtes
donc j'ai talent sur mme abileah qu
étant qu'il faut un bon coup de main
pour pouvoir bien établies ce sacré soit
bien bien rond sont là c'est une crête
de blé noir
donc on peut garnir avec un petit peu de
tours burrows eux et aussi manger le
matin au petit déjeuner avec du beurre
ces bons conseils et son savoir-faire
madame charpentier les trans fait
parfois de jeunes stagiaires qui
viennent dans sa crêperie pour apprendre
le métier
car à gourin il y a aussi un centre de
formation pour apprentis ou en quelques
mois sont enseignés les bases
incontournables de la profession
la fat et prend pas assez vite heures
danses et des portes vitres sur le jeu
si chaud que l'on essaie de leur
inculquer aussi c'est d'avoir les
différentes pâtes jeter à voir qu'on
puisse trouver sur la bretagne
s'ils vont ailleurs et peut aller
n'importe quel
leur peu de pâte qui est fabriqué en
bretagne c'est un métier qui permet de
bouger aussi sur les saisons aussi bien
amère que mental
ces futurs crêpier zékré pierre breton
pour la plupart sont les gardiens d'une
certaine tradition la bretagne compte
plus de 2000 crêperie dans cette région
la chandeleur c'est un petit peu tous
les jours